hi everyone I'm Callie and I'm here with
Miguel concepción and we're checking out
final fantasy 12 the zodiac age the
remaster of the almost ten-year-old
final fantasy 12 that came out on ps2
Miguel tonight we're looking at here
well we are at Ariat village my
apologies if I butchered these these
locations and character names I've never
actually taken the time to read up on
the proper pronunciation but that's okay
as you can see we are checking out Final
Fantasy 12 and rather cleaned up very
very polished look I mean for a game
that actually already looked pretty darn
good for PlayStation 2 game especially
when the console was at least eight
years old by the time this game came out
now it's looking even sharper so one
thing you were telling me about is
people checking out some ABS there was
some issues about Vaughn's ABS from the
original game and according to my
co-workers who have been watching me
play apparently they've been improved or
fixed fixed as far as a protagonist ABS
go washboard address um yeah so if you
played the US version this remaster has
some totally new updates and upgrades
but it also has stuff from international
versions that if you play it in the US
you wouldn't have seen so it's kind of a
combination of those two things which is
really really cool and also we get to
speed up which I love it was a it yeah
it was a feature in the international
version but I think this is a we're
currently watching it a two time speed I
don't know if four times speed was
available in the international version
but now you can actually play it four
times this week I'm also loving the
number of bunny girls in this game
yes this is uh this is Franz village so
I never played final fantasy 12 so I'm
excited to play it this time around and
just revisit revisiting it for you where
you played how many hours of final
fantasy 12 the first
around it must have been at least 200
nice having partly having to do with
being able to take my characters all the
way up to level 99 with a minimal amount
of input as we discussed in the previous
video yeah so if you want to check out
more of final fantasy 12 we do have more
of an in-depth look at the battle system
but right now we're just going to do
some exploring and talk about some
general changes and improvements and all
that stuff but be sure to check that
video out too because the battle system
is really really unique and cool and we
might touch on it a little bit here but
I'm that's probably the thing I'm most
excited about is the battle system yes
I'm about to head off into actually the
jungle angle which you know if you're
reeling to Final Fantasy but you just
somehow skipped a file fastly twelve you
should be able to find some similar or
some very familiar enemies you have
cacti you've got bombs I mean it's very
much the aesthetic is very much keeping
in line with the the ivelisse world that
we saw profile fancy tactics and vagrant
story but I believe just on the quality
alone you know it certainly earned its
place as a mainline Final Fantasy game
this is by how much of an aesthetic
departure it was um where does it rank
among your favorite final fantasy games
oh I didn't really even need to think
it's actually my favorite among all of
them okay I've heard that from some
people um when I asked because I'm a
despite what you would expect of
we have you like me I've never played a
Final Fantasy game so whenever I ask
people like where should I start
it's usually like people say six a lot
of the time and then when I asked about
favorites a lot of people bring up
twelve so I was really excited to hear
that there would be a remaster so in
relation to the Final Fantasy games
well Final Fantasy games are they get
away with each installment having its
own self-contained story I mean that's
the beauty of Final Fantasy games is
they're not tied to others except when
they you know I think it was the trend
started off a fancy tent where they had
ten - this game final fantasy 12 I would
have loved to have had more spin-offs
aside from the the the final fantasy 12
game that you ended up getting on the
Game Boy Advance but if you're big if
you're a big fan of vagrant story or
fantasy tactics you could definitely see
some of their similarities especially
when the initial director the character
designer and the the guy who did the
music all worked on vagrant story and
found fantasy tactics so you should be
able to like notice some aesthetic and
music similarities especially with
vagrant story because those games came
out maybe like six years apart from each
other yeah we talked about this in a
little bit in our video about the battle
system we talked about character a
little bit in that video - but I do
really want to explore like for somebody
who put 200 hours into this game the
first time around
why revisit it now like is it it's
something that is worth looking back on
because it has a lot of elements that
that work together really well like the
Battle of the story and things that work
together for a Final Fantasy game or is
it something else well this would be a
great opportunity to actually transition
into what they call the trials mode
let's go I'm of the opinion that and at
the risk of sounding very cornball about
it
there's a certain timelessness to the
game and in it and the foundation is the
battle system one sec it's all good a
notion of quick overview of everything
also a battle exploration that that this
world of evil ease this is this roughly
loosely shared universe that doesn't
involve filefast tactics and vagrant
story file fastly twelve I believe is or
the best example which features like the
best examples of those worlds especially
being like one of the last games to come
out from that game project yeah so and
for someone like me who has never played
a Final Fantasy do you think it would be
a good idea to play this first or should
I shall I start somewhere else you know
the despite this being like my favourite
Final Fantasy mm-hmm this isn't what I
would consider a good gateway Final
Fantasy big just because of how
drastically different the battle system
is right you know I mean I'm first in
JRPGs so like I'm not a JRPG newbie so
I'm very intrigued by the battle but for
Final Fantasy for somebody who's never
played this game has never played Final
Fantasy or maybe hasn't played a Final
Fantasy in a while you're saying this
isn't the best gateway despite being
your favorite no okay no that's good to
know I'm glad to know that I mean the
battle system is about us is so foreign
compared to most of the other final
fantasies mm-hmm very much in the same
way that the battle system of filefast
15 yeah isn't anything like anything
you've experienced at the other games I
think a lot of the single-digit Final
Fantasies I mean aside from prophecy
eight should be about a good gateway
installment as any
so like what we're looking at right now
is what they call it the trials mode
which is just these rounds of battles um
what do you get from it just doing
rounds of battles well you do get some
experience and you know actually now I
think about it I haven't had a chance to
actually read up on what they're like
the main benefit is but you know it's
definitely a nice way to showcase the
different environments and the different
enemies and especially when we're
thinking about a remaster seeing these
environments looking sharper and nicer
it's a nice little tour of that oh yeah
and let's all look at these boys I love
them and again if you are a Final
Fantasy aficionado you should be able to
recognize some enemies you know the one
of nice things about you know Final
Fantasy games is that the I guess the
the art team or the art director of each
respective Final Fantasy they do their
own twist on familiar of Final Fantasy
enemies mm-hmm this would be nice time
to also just showcase the the gambits
that these characters are working on for
all in that front is a very
straightforward support mm-hmm
well actually everyone has is pretty
strong and support so these are the
scripts you've written uh we do go into
this much more in-depth in another video
about the bow system but yeah yeah so
you have them kind of focused on support
you're all letting them do their thing
they're all animated here are em just
stick you lating I'm not even putting my
hands on the controller I could attest
to the fact that you are not even
touching the controller right now and
but at the same time because these are
my gambits these are my commands I still
feel invested in the moment mm-hmm and
that's something that intrigues me so
much about that game that this game that
makes me kind of want it to be my first
Final Fantasy is
that is so unique and so interesting
that I'm willing to bypass my better
judgment and just kind of go for it
especially from everything you've told
me about this game I am really really
intrigued and you know I know I'm ten
years too late to the party but if you
out there watching or like me
I'm curious let me know in the comments
if you also have a final fantasy and
would would feel comfortable starting
here just with that battle system alone
which is so cool you know maybe I'm that
age where I never give I have stopped
giving people on our time for like
skipping over a certain game it's like
you know bear late than ever yeah oh
yeah absolutely like you can't possibly
have time to play everything there's
just no way and this is a hefty RPG we
talked about in the other video too like
having a option to speed up gameplay
yeah let's do that
yes let's speed it up here um well
there's times for yeah while they're
kind of doing their thing with their
gambits I think that's also a really
cool addition especially if the time
sync is bit intimidating to you so
that's another thing that that makes me
kind of just want to like stop and play
this and kind of take a break from the
other games I've been playing just
because that like this four times you
could help shorten the amount of time
your your leveling up or or doing
anything and help get rid of that hurdle
I think and you know is this is
something you just need to be careful
with because if you're only say like
five eight ten hours into the game you
may not you a may not have all the ideal
gambits well you'll at least have the
essential gambits but you'll probably
end up some I mean it's not to say that
this game is going to be easy you're
you're probably going to be doing some
fine tuning throughout the journey and
yeah like you're not just gonna be
watching they're going to be learning
from what you've written the gambits
that you've set up and tweaking as you
go and seeing what works and what
doesn't
which is just a cool take on a battle
system that's less about like inputs and
more about
a pre-planning you know one thing I do
look forward to taking on eventually is
that there is a dragon-type boss later
in the game
he's optional he was named after the
original director of this game um and he
takes it takes about as I recall six
hours to beat Wow
yeah so that that's definitely one
reason why it's such a nice thing that
you could be hands-off yeah while still
having a sense of ownership with your
characters progress its success right
entirely it's just totally playing for
you you did the set which is super cool
um all right I know I've said it before
but we have another video about that
more in depth that you can check out
including the licenses system which has
been revamped for this version but we
have to wrap up so make sure you
subscribe to gang spawn on YouTube
because we have that other video on
final fantasy 12 zodiac age along with
other things coming out this game is
coming out not for a while so July 11
July 11th so subscribe so you don't miss
anything in the interim and thank you so
much for watching we'll see you next
time see you